Tasha: 喝吗
Tasha: Want a drink?
Jake:喝呵呵
Jake: Drink, hehe.
Tasha: 加冰块吗
Tasha: Want ice?
Tasha: 加的话自己帮我也拿一下
Tasha: If you do, help me get some too.
Jake:在哪里好子郎
Jake: Where's the good stuff, Zilang?
Jake:喝吧
Jake: Drink up.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 加冰块吗
Tasha: Want ice?
Tasha: 我怎么记得我开过口啊
Tasha: How do I remember opening it before?
Jake:我要把它给弄碎啊
Jake: I need to crush it.
Jake:他太大了
Jake: It's too big.
Jake:这么大
Jake: This big.
Jake:注水
Jake: Add water.
Tasha: 倒了你不喝
Tasha: If you pour it, you won't drink?
Tasha: 罪大恶极
Tasha: That's a serious crime.
Jake:哈哈哈没没不喝
Jake: Hahaha, no, no, I won't drink.
Jake:没不喝你们先挑
Jake: No, you guys pick first.
其他人：你在下面吃吗
Others: Are you eating downstairs?
Jake:在下面吃
Jake: Eating downstairs.
Jake:在下面吃还是在上面吃
Jake: Eating downstairs or upstairs?
Jake:可以在上面吃
Jake: We can eat upstairs.
Jake:当盒饭吃
Jake: Like a lunchbox.
Jake:我看要在外面吃得了
Jake: I think we should eat outside.
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, indeed.
Tasha: 在上面还是在下面
Tasha: Upstairs or downstairs?
Tasha: 都可以开空调
Tasha: Both can use the air conditioner.
Jake:在上面吃
Jake: Eat upstairs.
Jake:在下面吃
Jake: Eat downstairs.
Jake:你是你是吃
Jake: You, you are eating.
其他人：上面不是比较干净吗
Others: Isn't upstairs cleaner?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 你要去看吗
Tasha: Are you going to check it out?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:确实厉害
Jake: Really impressive.
Jake:这整了半个小时
Jake: This took half an hour.
Jake:整完一个小时
Jake: Took a full hour to finish.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Whoa.
Jake:处理数据
Jake: Processing data.
其他人：啊真的吗
Others: Oh, really?
Jake:没没没没考虑好呢
Jake: Not fully decided yet.
Jake:先先不说他
Jake: Let's not talk about it now.
其他人：他要是愿意为我报销的话
Others: If he's willing to reimburse me,
其他人：我会义无反顾
Others: I would have no hesitation.
其他人：勇往直前
Others: Move forward bravely.
Tasha: 这么好你们清华职务多吗
Tasha: How about you guys, do you have many positions at Tsinghua?
其他人：清华的话
Others: At Tsinghua,
其他人：嗯还行
Others: Yeah, it's okay.
Tasha: 我要做一个数据调查
Tasha: I want to do a data survey.
其他人：还行
Others: It's okay.
其他人：因为他他的西点就是非主要的教育区
Others: Because their west point is not the main educational area.
其他人：那边是沿着人流
Others: It's more about the flow of people.
Tasha: 那现在进去要预约吗
Tasha: Do you need an appointment to get in now?
其他人：就是你必须在他的公众号预约
其他人：好像每天要限额吧
Others: Seems like there is a daily limit.
其他人：就是今天开7天后
Others: You can book 7 days in advance.
Tasha: 这么严格
Tasha: So strict.
其他人：但其实周中一般都是不满
Other: But actually, midweek is usually not full.
其他人：但是五一肯定要满
Tasha: 谁五一去我
Tasha: Who's going on May Day, me.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 我肯定不会
Tasha: I definitely won't.
其他人：你就遥遥领先了
Other: You're way ahead.
其他人：西边是原来圆圆的园林
Other: The west side used to be a round garden.
其他人：小园林
Other: A small garden.
Tasha: 写篇小论文
Tasha: Write a short paper.
Tasha: 然后再搞个毕设毕业
其他人：好毕设
Other: Good, graduation project.
其他人：靠这是我毕设
Other: Damn, this is my project.
其他人：平板还没写
Other: Haven't written on the tablet yet.
其他人：哇差MD翻译
Other: Wow, damn MD translation.
Jake:please translate this paragraph into Chinese
Jake: Please translate this paragraph into Chinese.
其他人：你猜微信能写歌吗
Other: Do you think WeChat can write songs?
Tasha: 不知道啊杨老板
Tasha: No idea, Jake.
Tasha: 哦苏诺
Tasha: Oh, Shure.
Tasha: 干什么
Tasha: What's up?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 是吗杨老板
Tasha: Really, Jake?
Tasha: 杨老板你为什
Tasha: Jake, why don't
Tasha: 么不出来改
Tasha: you come out to change?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake:这边比较快
Jake: It's faster here.
其他人：现在是什么环节
Other: What part is it now?
其他人：我马上要吃饭
Other: I'm about to eat.
其他人：我要饿死了
Other: I'm starving.
Jake:吃饭
Jake: Eating.
Jake:对不知道是什么环节
Jake: Yeah, no idea what part.
Jake:应该是收眼镜
Jake: Should be collecting glasses.
Jake:那个他
Jake: That guy
Jake:他们人呢
Jake: where are they?
Jake:他们在干嘛
Jake: What are they doing?
Alice:他们是不是在楼上
Alice: Are they upstairs?
Alice:先把它拿出来吧
Alice: Take it out first.
其他人：4散开来啊
Other: Spread out.
其他人：4就是在干自己的事
Other: Everyone's doing their own thing.
Jake:他们在干嘛呀
Jake: What are they doing?
Jake:那那几个剧组呢
Jake: And those crews?
其他人：都在上面哎
Others: Everyone's up there
其他人： 董三杀不知道在干嘛
Others: No idea what Jack is doing
Jake:那个把那个谢斌竹他们谢斌竹和刘帅下来
Jake: Hey, have Shure and Choiszt come down
其他人：给在玩乐器
Others: They're playing instruments
Jake:那不行给叫下来
Jake: No, get them down here
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure: 吃饭不积极
Shure: Not enthusiastic about eating
Shure: 思想有问题
Shure: Got a problem with your mindset
Jake:谢斌竹和刘帅呢
Jake: Where are Shure and Choiszt?
Jake:你收眼镜
Jake: Get your glasses
Jake:收眼镜别他妈玩了啊
Jake: Get your glasses and stop messing around
其他人：哎那几人在
Others: Hey, those guys are here
Jake:不不不带了
Jake: No, no, no, they're coming with us
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn
Jake:这扣钱啊
Jake: This is gonna cost us money
其他人：插上
Others: Plug it in
Jake:这个
Jake: This one
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:插上插上
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in
Jake:都装装装
Jake: All set, all set
其他人： 这个电脑有指定的话随便插啊
Others: If this computer has specific ports, just plug it in anywhere
Jake:有有有你低位差是吧
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, you plug it in low, right?
Jake:第一回插
Jake: First time plugging in
Jake:就是你看这个每一个口
Jake: See, each port
Jake:你你你没那
Jake: You, you, you don't have that
Jake:那你吃饭时录吧好吧
Jake: Then record while eating, okay?
Katrina: 就是早上也录了蛮久
Katrina: Yeah, we recorded a lot in the morning
Jake:OK行行就就是你还有空间
Jake: OK, fine, fine, as long as you have space
Jake:如果有空间就可以再拍一下对
Jake: If there's space, we can shoot more, right
Shure: 太好了我就喜欢这样的人
Shure: Great, I just love people like this
其他人：这个是插哪
Others: Where does this plug in?
其他人：插这边
Others: Plug it here
Jake:你就看那个小条啊
Jake: Just look at the small strip
Jake:这个没有小条啊
Jake: This one doesn't have a small strip
Jake:这这个没小条你就随便插
Jake: This one doesn't, so just plug it anywhere
其他人：就插那个口对
Others: Just plug it into that port, yeah
Jake:不是就是别的
Jake: No, it's just that
Jake:你有小你有小条
Jake: You have a small strip
Jake:一定要掐着小条啊
Jake: You gotta catch the small strip
Jake:嗯然后中间l的话无所谓
Jake: Yeah, and if it's in the middle, it doesn't matter
其他人：无所谓
Other: Doesn't matter
Jake:l的话很有所为其实
Jake: Actually, it really does matter if it's L
Jake:但是你先不用管
Jake: But you don't have to worry about it
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:就是它它已经不能被定义了
Jake: It can't be defined anymore
其他人：然后这个要怎么导
Other: So, how do we export this?
Jake:就是它出来之后它会有两个
Jake: So when it comes out, there will be two of them
Jake:对就这些东西
Jake: Yes, just these things
其他人：就这6个
Other: Just these six
Jake:这些这对这些
Jake: These, yes, these
Jake:然后
Jake: And then
Jake:你找一个你你找到这个要新建一个你
Jake: You find one, you need to create a new one
Jake:421
Jake: 421
Jake:你不能复制里边很多东西
Jake: You can't copy a lot of things inside
其他人：然后都放都
Other: And then put them all
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:复制过去
Jake: Copy them over
其他人：就是VRS和这个 XS对
Other: It's VRS and this XS, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Jake:然后文件夹子不要做
Jake: And don't make any folders
Jake:文件夹不要
Jake: No folders
Jake:谢斌竹在干什么呀
Jake: What is Xie Binzhu doing?
其他人：不知道，他在坐着
Jake:坐着
Jake: Sitting down
Jake:坐着是什么东西
Jake: What is sitting down?
其他人：打电话呢
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh my
其他人：这个格式都不一样啊
其他人：你看它这个点VRS写VRS文件
Other: Look at this, it writes the VRS file here
其他人：然后这个是点js啊
Other: And here it points to js
其他人：然后这里这个是VR
Other: And here this is VR
其他人：这个是VRS
Other: This is VRS
其他人：然后这个点VRS是JS
Other: And this points to VRS as JS
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's fine, it's fine
Jake:因为它这个它这个VRS点结层
Jake: Because this VRS points to the structure
Jake:它是这样的
Jake: It's like this
Jake:你看明白了不
Jake: Do you understand now?
Jake:嗯就是那个v就是点VRS
Jake: Hmm, so the V points to VRS
Jake:就是vs格式
Jake: It's the VS format
Jake:点VRS点JS就是JS格式
Jake: VRS pointing to JS is the JS format
Jake:然后它的文件名叫点VRS
Jake: And its file name is VRS
其他人：找一下眼镜
Other: Look for the glasses
Jake:然后充电宝都充电
Jake: And make sure all the power banks are charged
Jake:谢斌竹
Jake: Xie Binzhu
其他人：哎
Others: Hey
Jake:充电宝都拿去充
Jake: Charge all the power banks
Jake:就是除了像除了go Pro的
Jake: Except for the GoPro ones
Jake:别的充电宝都问一圈找一圈
Jake: Check and charge all other power banks
Jake:除了go Pro的都都充电
Jake: Charge everything except the GoPro ones
Jake:充电宝全都充电
Jake: Charge all the power banks
其他人：你这个L4是什么啊
Others: What's this L4?
其他人：你这个文件夹里这个L4啊
Others: In this folder, what's this L4?
Jake:这个不管
Jake: Ignore that
Jake:这个一个遗留问题问
Jake: It's an old issue, don't worry about it
其他人：2024
Others: 2024
其他人：这边还有没有能充电的口了
Others: Are there any available charging ports here?
Jake:有
Jake: Yes
Jake:找找
Jake: Look for them
其他人：这是什么
Others: What's this?
其他人：这种情况
Others: What's going on?
Jake:哪种情况
Jake: What situation?
其他人：这个我一一在说
Others: I'll explain each one
其他人：出错我拔了重插一下
Others: If there's an error, I'll unplug and replug it
Jake:我我不太好
Jake: I'm not very good at it
Jake:就你的眼镜还有吧
Jake: Do you still have your glasses?
其他人：还有啊还有三个
Others: Yeah, I still have three pairs
Jake:还有三个孔呢
Jake: There are still three ports
其他人：S1 S1在录
Others: S1 is recording
其他人：刘宇轩在录
Others: Liu Yuxuan is recording
其他人：然后那个姜茹亚的那个眼睛
Others: And Jiang Ruya's glasses
其他人：这是谁的
Others: Whose is this?
Lucia: 这个是我的
Lucia: This is mine
Lucia: 那个是那个哈哈哈
Lucia: That one is, haha
其他人：L3
Others: L3
其他人：就直接滴就行
Others: Just drop it directly
其他人：这个好刺激
Others: This is exciting
其他人：这个L3你看一眼L3电池故障
Others: Look at this L3, battery malfunction